[Music]
[Applause]
we welcome back the Super Bowl MVP with
the Saints Hall of Famer Drew Brees
joining us on the program good to see
you again what do you remember most
about going to the combine
when you played
yeah it was uh
you know the thing I remember most was I
was for whatever reason I was most
worried about the 40-yard dash
um so I feel like so much of my my focus
from call it January February leading up
to it was uh you know how well can I run
how much of an athlete can I show people
I am because you know all of the
um I think all that people were saying
was he's you know he's too short not not
enough arm strength um you know all
those deficiencies and so I felt like I
had to make up for it in some other way
you know with with athleticism so I
remember focusing on the L drill
the vertical and especially the 40-yard
dash do you remember your time
yeah 482 uh was the electronic time
um but apparently you know the guys are
in the stands you know the scouts with
their hand time and so it was as fast as
465 is what I was told oh um but 482
electronic
um and so I felt good about that but
unfortunately I didn't throw the ball
very well at the combine
um
so so and I I should have realized that
you know what it really wasn't about the
40-yard dash it was about how you throw
what did you think when you saw Michael
Vick run the 40-yard dash he was at the
same combine with you but yeah you know
here he didn't need to run you just you
just turn on the film and you know
exactly what you're getting with him
well that's what I I'm I we we do fall
in love with the combine numbers and if
I watched you play at Purdue
I saw what you know like we get caught
up in that and I think sometimes teams
talk themselves into something or out of
something based off the combine
do you say that's a fair sense you are
you're exactly right
um so we call it measurables right
um everyone's looking at the measurables
so is it how how far you can throw or
how fast you can throw how fast the ball
gets there how fast you run how high you
jump right
um at the end of the day especially with
the quarterback position I feel like 90
of it is you know between your ears
um and and in your chest you know so
um
the way the way I would evaluate
quarterbacks is I want to turn on the
film and I want to watch the way they
play the game the way they process the
game the way they work through
progressions their anticipation you know
uh how they can throw Guys open
um and then I want to talk to their
teammates I want to talk to the
equipment managers I want to talk to the
trainers I want to talk to everybody in
the building tell me about this guy
right what type of personality is he is
what type of leader he is uh you know
give me examples of when you've been in
tough situations how this guy's
responded how do you feel when this guy
steps in the Huddle I mean to me those
are the immeasurables those are the
intangibles yeah
um
and that's the stuff that's most
important but if you look at Bryce young
he's a little bit shorter than you
um I think you weighed a little bit more
than him if I'm you know combine numbers
I think you were six feet about 213
something like that yeah but what really
matters with Bryce young what would
matter to you if you're the GM of the
Bears or the Texans Colts you know what
are you what are you looking at and what
would you be concerned about
the only thing I'd be concerned about is
maybe durability just based on what
you've said right if he's a little bit
more slight in stature
um you know is that is that going to be
an issue with you know just making your
way through a 17 Game season and you
know some of the abuse that your body
takes
um I know they
you know the league takes better
quarterbacks now than they did you know
20 years ago
um but still that's uh that would be the
only if you'd say concern I mean I think
some guys are able to stay healthier
than others for various reasons as a
quarterback there's plenty of times
where you're just in vulnerable
positions and it is what it is
um but
bottom line you turn on the film with
Bryce young and man the guy the guy
who's Got Talent the guy makes plays the
guy throws with anticipation he is a
smart player he knows where to go with
the football he can avoid right I think
a lot of a lot of playing the
quarterback position now is can you
avoid slide move get buy yourself a
little extra time to be able to make
that play or get outside the pocket in
order to make that play
um you know that's kind of the evolution
of the quarterback position that we're
starting to see
if you ran the Ravens uh what would you
be doing with Lamar Jackson
well
I think he is an extremely talented
player
um I love the way he plays the game
from everything I've seen with his
teammates and guys that I know who
played with him they love him they love
him as a teammate they love him as a
leader
um it's really how you want to build
your system I think Baltimore has always
been this
you know
physical style of football both
offensively and defensively very
aggressive defensively high pressure but
it's but the division in which they play
you know they play in the Northeast
um it's a ground ground you know game
emphasis
um if that's the direction you want to
go then Lamar Jackson's your quarterback
um if you want to go a different
direction the style of offense that you
play then
you know I guess you're going to get
somebody else but do you care about the
price tag should he get what DeSean
wants uh Watson got
I don't know I mean again it it there's
uh you look at you look at every team
that has a quarterback that's reached
that next contract
and it certainly has an effect on your
team you know the teams that have
drafted a guy well or they they have
them you know cheap so to speak you know
because they're on their rookie deal
they have the ability to go out and and
spend money elsewhere for a period of
time
until that guy is up and and is getting
that big number
um so it certainly impacts the team once
they reach that level
uh Derek Carr going to your Saints your
reaction
yeah I think it's a great fit I think
it's a great fit for him I think it's a
great fit for the Saints
um I've always been impressed with Derek
Carr
um I think he's been in a pretty
dysfunctional situation
um I think we all recognize that um he's
been
I mean look at all that's happened to
the Raiders both from a Personnel
perspective and just you know all the
controversy and everything that swirled
around them for the last couple years
you know that's a very difficult
situation to be and I think he's caught
the brunt of that unfairly in a lot of
ways I've always been impressed watching
him play
I think
um he certainly has the ability to take
an offense like what the Saints run and
and and execute that well you know put a
lot on his plate you know where you know
in many cases you're going up to the
line of scrimmage with multiple plays or
the ability to check in and out of place
I've seen him do that
um you know John Gruden's offense which
is what he you know he came up in was
the same offense that we run it's this
that West Coast style but the ability to
hey we're not going to run a bad play
you know that was always the philosophy
we're gonna get out of that place get
into good plays you got to be a smart
quarterback to do that you have to
recognize what's happening on the other
side I always felt like you did a good
job of that
um so I think it's a good fit talking to
Drew Brees do you think Brady is
officially retired
yeah I I think so
um look I I don't know but nobody wants
to retire if they can still play
right
at that position
yeah look I I that was that was always
if I gave you perfect health
you might still be planned
yeah but look there's a sacrifice that
goes along with that you know you you
have to be so fully invested in in what
you're doing especially as the
quarterback you know so much falls on
your shoulders
and when you are you are the caliber
player that Tom Brady is or at that
level you you take that burden on
yourself you take so much of the burden
maybe more so than you deserve or should
but you do and only those who have been
in that position know what that feels
like
um so literally
call it seven months but really it's the
whole year where your mind is just
consumed with being the best quarterback
you can be for your team being the best
leader you could be for your team you
just you shoulder so much of that
responsibility
um and that's where your mind is so it's
very hard to to turn that off it's very
hard to pull yourself away from that
um and and other things sacrifice as a
result
um I mean golly the guy played for 23
years you know at the highest level
um and you know I think I I there's
always that adjustment when you do step
away you know I certainly know that was
the way it was for me I mean here I am
two years
from my you know official announcement
of retirement and man there's plenty of
days where I wake up and and I'm still
in that mode of like man what what do I
have to do today you know that that that
uh that structure and routine that
football you know gave you and and you
feel like something is is missing a
little bit
how often would you have those
conversations with your wife that you
weren't present as as a father and a
husband
yeah you know we I think I I I tried to
be very mindful of that and and
recognize that um especially in the
latter stages of my career when my kids
were getting that age where
um
you know being present was so important
and you know you're having
much more real conversations you know
it's not like you you know they're at
that baby or infant stage I mean they're
at this stage now where I mean you can
have have real conversations and
um
I I would say the balance in my life
like that really gave me great balance
in my life because I knew that when I
left the facility I was leaving that
behind and I was totally focusing on you
know my family when I got home and and
we had kind of our our own little
routine when I would get home reading
books to the kids before bed you know
talking about the day you know saying
our prayers
um
you know it was it was it was really
like honestly I felt like that put me in
a much even better headspace uh when it
came to then waking up the next day and
doing it again uh my kids recognized
what their dad did they had a chance to
be a part of that they had a chance to
come in the locker and they had a chance
to be there on game day and and
afterward you know so there was this
recognition of what their dad did the
fact that their dad was you know working
hard
um represented not just his team but you
know the city and you know so many other
aspects of what the job entailed did
your kids ever actually got more fun it
got more fun your kids ever asked for
autographs from the opposition the
opposing team
well the the best was I mean there was
there was like funny moments that you
know like I I remember we I think we
played the Houston Texans back in 2015.
J.J watt Got after us pretty good you
know I feel like he was hitting me every
play and uh so I get home it was a road
game I get home it's kind of you know
later in the evening seven o'clock at
night I get home and the kids are like
you know I knew right when I walked in
the door I gotta let the game go we had
lost we got beat up a little bit let the
game go be with the kids I walk in the
door and the kids are like Hey Dad let's
let's play football like all right guys
let's do it you know and they're like
okay you you be Drew Brees I'm like okay
I can do that and they're like and we'll
be we'll be JJ Watt can you stand there
and we're just gonna like tap on you
like oh that sounds great yeah
uh who's risking more the Packers if
they let Rogers go or the Jets in
acquiring Aaron Rodgers
well um
who's risking more I I mean I I think I
think that's a that's a better deal for
the Jets
um but you don't even know how long you
get him for I mean you might be but but
look it's a window of opportunity okay
uh I I mean let look at look at the Rams
and and basically the what they
attempted to do two years ago when they
won the Super Bowl right I mean they
basically mortgage the future you go out
you trade for for Stafford you trade for
Von Miller right you get you get obj
right you make all these moves literally
with the attempt to win right now this
season
um and in in a way you mortgage your
future as a result of it but you you
sense the window of opportunity and you
do everything you can to to get it done
so
in a way you know depending on what that
number is you know and what they trade
and you know that kind of thing that's
basically what you're doing you say we
got a talented roster we got some young
guys that we don't have to pay yet
let's let's make this trade let's pay
Rogers let's make a run out the next two
years or whatever it is and then
just you know forget the future just
focus on these next two years going to
win do you know Rogers at all
I don't not really
I think we're all still trying to figure
him out
foreign
I think that's pretty accurate statement
well that see that's what makes me
nervous too I don't know how I don't
know how important football is to him
and I do love what the Jets have I mean
they got offensive Rookie of the Year
Defensive Rookie of the Year they they
have that potential I just feel like
there might be two years away
or maybe even a little bit more and is
Roger's going to be around for that
that'd be the risk there with that you
know is he going to get together with
those receivers is going to be all in on
the off season and that that's where I
think you run the risk yeah look I think
I think when you go to a new team though
um and look Brady Brady could attest
this
um you know there's a bit of this
Rejuvenation right you know he he leaves
New England nobody ever thought he'd
leave New England just like nobody
thought Peyton would leave Denver right
but uh
um next thing you know they're they're
on a new team but but there's a bit of
this Rejuvenation that takes place
um in feeling like you're you're
building up the foundation again but not
just that but
you feel like you can be the architect
of that in a lot of ways you know
because of your your experience and
um
you know the level of respect that
you've gone but also like you know the
things that you like you know what works
for you you know what is going to help
you and the offense be successful you
and the team be successful
so I think that that most guys
um would take that as a great challenge
or great opportunity and would be all in
how confident are you that Sean Payton
can fix Russell Wilson
well I just know I know what Sean brings
to the table
um from the perspective of leadership
communication
and really building a winning culture
um I think that's a talented roster I
think that's a great fit
um that was a great move by them to to
go get them
um
I think I think again Sean similar to
the quarterback going somewhere else
same with Sean Payton like this is a
rejuvenating time for him you know uh
another challenge another opportunity I
mean this is right up his alley this is
what he does best
um
and Sean does an exceptional job of
taking the talents of the guys that he
has at his disposal and putting them in
the best position to succeed so this
offense will be built around Russell
Wilson and the things that he does best
um and the pieces that he has around him
good to visit with you
hope the boys are keeping you active
there
that's good we were just before this we
were out in the yard learning how to
throw a slider you know it's baseball
season so
do you want him to be baseball players
or football players I want him to be all
sports players good for as long as
possible good so at this point they
don't really take anything too serious
um which I'm kind of waiting for them to
like really you know lock in on on a
sport
but uh they're playing a little bit of
everything which that's that's what I
like we play golf we play paddle Sports
football basketball baseball lacrosse
just have it have it have a have a stick
in their hand or a ball in their hand or
a glove or something just moving good
stuff good to talk to you thanks for
joining us Drew you too thanks Dan it's
Drew Brees